true sales doesn't feel like sales it
just feels like making an informed
decision with somebody who is an expert
who helps you make the best decision for
you you help the person that you're
speaking to decide not that they buy
think about it like this you're side by
side with them you've got a sword and
they don't and they're like the monsters
are in here and you're like all right
let's open the doors that's the role of
the salesman it's like you can kill
these demons in front of them you're
like it's not your husband's
responsibility it's not the fact that
you don't have time because I can
promise you there's someone who's had it
worse has done better and so you can
have those real conversations